لا توجد اي مشاكل في الطرق الواصله الى
المدن هذه المدن المنكوبه هذا ولكن هناك
فقط مشكله بطلب المواطنين ان يدخلوا الى
هذه
الاماكن بسيارتهم الخاصه وهذا ما يتسبب
بازدحام
كثير في هذه المدن في الطرق الواصله الى
هذه المدن لذلك نرجو من المواطنين الا
يتوافدوا الى هذه المدن بسيارتهم الخاصه
قدر المستطاع بامكانهم ان يصلوا جريا على
الاقدام ولكن نرجو ان لا يتوفدوا الى هذه
المدن بسيارتهم الخاصه ربما
يستطيعون
بالحافلات الكبيره او عبر الخطوط الطيران
وما شابه ولكن نرجو الا يتوافدوا
بسياراتهم الخاصه ويتسببوا هنا بازدحام في
السير اثناء الدخول الى هذه نحن لن نغادر
هذه المدن قبل الانتهاء من البحث والانقاذ
المطارات تعمل بشكل كثيف وبشكل سليم
مطهرها فقط هو الذي خارج يعتبر خارج عن
الخدمه بسبب
انهيار الذي حصل به وبسبب بعض الاضرار
الذي اصاب الطرق الواصله الى المطار ايضا
لذلك هناك اعمال كثيفه نراها فقط نحتاج
تامين
ربما طريقه تقديم هذه المساعدات طبعا
تضامن الشعب هو مصدر اما بالنسبه الينا
وحماس بالنسبه لكن نرجو الا تكون هناك
استخدام للسيارات الخاصه كما ذكرنا طبعا
القطارات ايضا
قمنا بتاهيلها بحيث تستضيف اكبر عدد ممكن
من العجينه من هذه الزلازل هم الان
يتواجدون في في مدينه هاتاي وما حول